welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki's latest episode left us
with so many questions about who
is truly pulling the timekeeper strings
where loki is now and whether or not
it's been loki gator all along
with only two episodes left there are
only so many ways the remaining not yet
shown in episodes footage from the
trailers and promos could go
so i'm gonna break down everything
marvel has teased but has yet to be seen
in an episode to try to decode loki's
endgame first there's this imagery of
president loki come on
what did you expect
president loki is a nod to the 2016 vote
loki series in which loki runs for
president on the platform that he's not
afraid to lie to voters now here he's
surrounded by this ragtag group dressed
in
a license plate suit a helmet with
silverware sticking out a helmet with a
bike handlebar another helmet to the far
right with a huge
tree growing out of it but over to the
left side is a pelebius game this is the
urban legend from the portland area of
an arcade game
that government agents might have rigged
with mind control algorithms but
polybius probably didn't even exist
or maybe it did but another yet to be
seen shot in the same location
shows these warriors fighting with a new
loki variant we just met in episode 4
boastful loki who carries a makeshift
mjolnir made from a piston shaft and a
piece of train rail behind them is a
throne with an
l over it probably for loki but perhaps
also ironically l for
loser since sylvia was concerned loki's
are destined to lose but
these loki's are at least all rejects so
i think we can expect to see this in
episode 5
with our loki joining these other
variants in this mystery exile that
includes some pieces of new york to mix
it up with this eccentric loki gang
but is this exile a timeline and history
or a branch history or is it some
closed-off pocket reality limbo where
time doesn't exist and is it populated
with loki variants only or
everyone who has been pruned including
mobius and c20 well if you look at the
other footage this exile
starts to look more like a pocket
reality with all kinds of interesting
historical artifacts
beyond the pelevius arcade game but
before it continued thanks to rage
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
if your to-do list today doesn't include
defeating the clan boss
or ascending a doom tower you gotta
rearrange your priorities you gotta use
the links below to download raid to your
mobile phone or pc
raid has hundreds of champions but
here's a little list of the top four
scariest looking ones in my opinion you
got little miss annie evil dolls always
scary candrafen he looks more like an
evil davey jones
from pirates of the caribbean uras soul
cage his head is just too
small for the body and mashallah he's
like a big hairless man bat
and it's super creepy but what i really
like about this game is the character
design the artists at raid are famous
for their attention to detail and
incredible design all the characters i
mentioned
have cool attack graphics to go along
with their character design now raid's
got a non-stop schedule of summer events
and activities
with special fusion events tournaments
against other players and much more
they're
also releasing five amazing new
champions and raid summer plans are just
starting to heat up and there are some
giant updates coming very very soon so
there's never really been a better time
to get started and if you want to get a
huge head start in raid all you have to
do is hit the link in the description
and you'll get an
epic hero chonoru who's amazing in the
doom tower 200
000 silver one xp boost one energy
refill and one
ancient shard so that you can summon an
awesome champion as soon as you get in
game
and all of this treasure will be waiting
for you right up here and once you're in
you can find me
in game under the name newrock2020 and
if you're fast you can join my clan and
it's that easy just click the link in
the description and i'll see you
in the game the uss eldridge vessel
drops in that was a world war ii era
ship part of a debunked philadelphia
experiment conspiracy theory in which it
was claimed to have been cloaked with an
invisibility shield but here notice as
it falls it re-materializes from the
same bright multicolored glow
that envelops people in objects as they
are pruned this could tell us that a
number of historical curiosities i don't
like how loki was revealed as the
mystery hijacker didi cooper all these
other things could derive their mystery
around having been part of a branch
history pruned by the tva because also
in this region
is another shipwreck but appears to be a
much older wooden vessel with three
masks
some torn sails and some light boats on
the deck this could be the wreckage of
the santa maria christopher columbus's
flagship that sank upon hitting a coral
reef near present-day haiti but was
never found but behind that i could be
wrong here but that kind of looks like a
typical flying saucer does it not like
the mcu has a variety of
extraterrestrials with different looking
spacecraft but this could be one typical
flying saucer that was spotted by humans
but then pruned into this pocket reality
but behind both of these in the sky on
the left appears to be some portal made
of that same multicolored glow as the
pruning this could be the access point
like those portals that dump trash on
the sakar landfills with other footage
of loki and sylvie running across this
terrain and loki pointing a supercharged
sword at the sky
could be them trying to break out of
this exile but this exile might not be
exclusive to loki variants because in
other footage of this
cloudy skied grassy landscape mobius
drives past the great sphinx and the
pyramids of giza and then off to the
right some other structure that i don't
believe is located near giza perhaps
some other ancient ruins
like what the original intent of
stonehenge was now i have pointed out in
other videos how in the domed kingdom of
chronopolis
marvel time bill and kang the conqueror
collects historical trophies that do
include the pyramids in the sphinx from
his time as sparrow rama tut but there's
also footage of mobius re-entering rinse
layer's office armed with a charged
pruning stick and his ties tugged to
skew i don't think we've seen this yet
so i think this guy's gonna make it out
of exile back into the tva similarly
there's a shot of loki with his sleeve
sliced and bloody which he got
in that fight at the end of episode 4
now in the tba bullpen with a
multi-handed clock hanging down so we
can expect he too will return to the tva
but i'll say what makes it tough to
determine the exact narrative of this
footage is that we also see various
shots of loki seemingly at the top of
his game
first there's a shot from the first loki
teaser glorious
yeah the mirror in the scepter tell us
that loki is back in tony stark's
penthouse at the top of stark tower in
the first avengers film so we may see a
flashback or a redo of those moments
also there's a king loki in front of the
throne of asgard but it's been
redesigned from the version odin sat
upon with his ravens
here there are green flags showing
loki's heraldry and he's being applauded
by asgardian nobles which might include
thor
and loki comics writer walt simonsen on
the right there
he cameoed as an asgardian in the first
thor film i wonder if these could be
flashbacks of other loki variants that
our loki meets in this exile each of
them telling the tale how they were
plucked from their glorious ascendancies
and then pruned into this limbo but one
major set piece features loki in this
indigo-colored castle that's streaked
with golden cracks
sylvie will actually join him in this
setting because we see her doing some
moves in a library with a roaring
fireplace beside a few
handles or levers i'm guessing this
could be the residence of whoever is
controlling the timekeepers
our man behind the curtain be it he who
remains or
kang or another loki or some alternate
form of missed minutes but where
is this we might get a huge clue by
looking at what i see as the most
cryptic
shots of all the remaining footage first
some cosmic shots of our solar system
then our galaxy and beyond it some
floating satellites and then some trippy
stargate footage and then
this jagged rock ring or donut floating
in space with a shimmery
beam behind it but now in the latest
rendered version of this shot
there is a tiny detail that wasn't
visible the first time we saw the shot
may 5th on top of that rock ring there
is a tiny
glowing structure almost like a
lighthouse for a lookout
station this could be where the whole
tva is located or
it could be a station at the end of all
time the last
piece of livable terrain left in the
universe from which the one
pulling the levers of the tva operates
let me know your theories for the final
two episodes and you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options including this loki inspired
shirt
loki out of time at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter eavos follow and
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you